les salariés des principales enseignes
de bricolage mobilisés sur les réseaux
sociaux
objectif conserver le droit au travail
dominical est sur le terrain aussi il ne
manque pas l'occasion de faire passer
leurs messages comme ici à bois d'arcy
c'est complètement basé sur le
volontariat on signe tous les ans des
feuilles on met le nombre de dimanches
qu'on souhaite faire ou pas si on n'est
pas volontaire on le met aussi pour dire
qu'on ne souhaite pas travailler le
dimanche
à moi ça me gêne absolument pas trahi
dimanche étant donné que je suis en
cours toute la semaine du lundi au
vendredi pour moi travailler le week-end
ça me permet de pas du tout inquiétés
sur ma semaine de cours donc tous les
jours donc c'est vraiment parfait et en
plus de ça on a rémunéré en conséquence
donc pour moi c'est un bénéfice et c'est
nécessaire comment ça représente aucun
problème ce problème c'est qu'on soit
obligé de se battre pour bourrage raillé
dimanche
les salariés sont quasi unanimes quant
au fait de travailler le dimanche
les clients aussi sont enthousiastes
même s'il ne semble pas favorable à une
généralisation de l'ouverture dominicale
à l'ensemble des commerces
je suis plutôt contre l'ouverture des
magasins le dimanche
mais tant qu'ils sont ouverts j'y vais
mais je comprendrais très bien que les
gens ne veulent plus travailler le
dimanche c'est tout à fait normal c'est
un peu plus au cas par cas face avec le
bricolage on fait souvent sale week-end
après les courses
enfin pour l'alimentaire par exemple
j'ai moins d'avis là dessus parce qu'en
fait ça la semaine tant que l'employé
s'y retrouve c'est bien si l'oeil et se
retrouve la loi encadre de manière
stricte l'ouverture le dimanche les
magasins doivent être situés dans une
zone touristique où sur un puce un
périmètre d'usagé de consommation
exceptionnel certes un brave les
interdits comme bricorama qui a été
assigné en justice est interdit d'ouvrir
le dimanche
le dimanche cela faire les embauches
étaient sûrs et après la pluie il a
fallu revoir après le la restructuration
du magasin afin de combler les pertes
suite à ce verdict bricorama assigné en
justice deux de ses concurrents
leroy merlin et castorama qui sont
ouverts le dimanche